today on our show man we have our very
first guests ever I don't know what to
do with this man this place is getting
crowded all right stick around is about
to start good i'm batman with guests
what
welcome to Batman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith mark barnard we never do this but
no we this is gonna be strange but fun I
know this who knows you begin this sort
of thing might continue on and on and on
normally we talk to each other nobody
ever wants to talk about today we got
people to talk to we have new friends uh
and the good news is it isn't like local
comic enthusiast Jimmy Johnson
we actually got some [ __ ] legit
people kind of nut uh take it away I'll
let you intros Yeah right we have a
sugar of the four no no no no no no no
you got a surprise you got build up all
right
one of these guys is very tall the other
one is also tall they are both actors
they were both on a show ones that
everybody loves that went away too soon
this is [ __ ] hack listen to this [ __ ]
one of these guys home is his castle and
the other guy's so [ __ ] big he's got
two dicks all right before uniformly
alan tudyk yes Fillion look at we did a
thing Oh get tall
yes there we go oh my quads are just
completely jacked nothing like those
people were just like wow it looks tall
around screen there it is he stands on a
box party um these guys obviously very
very uh busy and very very famous so
we're gonna try to get them back to
their realize but they came here to talk
about this thing they're working on
called common conmen work on man con man
singular con man just the one
well it's cuz man takin plural was too
tough well it mainly focuses on one man
so it's all about you it is [ __ ] hey
what about like the Six Million Dollar
Man we go right like six month old man
that's true good right one way I won of
the [ __ ] PluralEyes if you don't have
to you know if I'm gonna tell them what
to do they all right no okay
neighbor's character is too famous to
really be a con man he doesn't go to as
many cons as Rey nearly does he plays
Jack more after a space show is
cancelled way too soon he ends up this
is his career Rainier lease just bottoms
out and then where do you get an idea
like this huh came in the night but he
doesn't like cons that's
the differences that nearly resents his
life and you're like Matt Damon famous
in this thing whereas right now you're
just like Ben Affleck
which is sad to see you're a Martian
away and abandoned the true possibility
um
so wait take me back where did it begin
crowdsource financing mm-hmm you were
one of those people that whatever I'm
little oh my god they raised a lot of
money that was you guys yeah what
happened but before that we actually
went to some people asked him for some
money and said we'd like to do something
else produce something and the deals
were not the greatest they're kind of
sour and at the end of the day arrested
control from our hands and we were kind
of concerned about that being that
people don't really understand the world
so much if they're not in it and they're
not involved they use nerd as a
derogatory term you know you know those
crazy weird people and they're talking
to us and that's our bread and butter we
love it I'm a nerd I like the comic
books in the cartoons because you're in
real life you two are [ __ ] passing so
they can sit there and be like he's
[ __ ] nerds right now Yeah right
exactly yeah in meetings yeah those
weird weird convention nerds they would
talk down weekly meetings over I am
those people so they weren't coughing up
the money you guys were like what the
[ __ ] yeah we just we were concerned
about pending over control that someone
who didn't understand it or respect it
right so we said what if we did this on
a row that was was it PG or was it you
said that PJ first said it and I said no
and then I said yes mmm who's DJ PJ
Haar's Mazar the producer yes did a lot
of the nose to the grindstone style
working well Alan was busy himself with
the creative stuff yeah the day-to-day
though was that was all you had a
partner your battery the person without
whom you can't jump on set yeah
absolutely nothing the only reason he's
not here is today's he's just not that
answer right that's all right positive
hell of a panel right here like how did
I get into this well if this new kid
goes on fire it's gonna be like three
famous people died here their names and
a black guy
the black guy and the other unnamed the
black you're good
the all right so wait a second you you
let's do your bona fides before we talk
about the moment you jump in to
crowdsource financing aside from your
many acting credits just didn't eat
world for those who are you know I don't
[ __ ] I'm unfamiliar tell them what you
guys have done in the geek space my
first foray into the geek world was in
Outer Limits episode really I did not
limit them than absolutely Outer Limits
and I remember they give you a nice
trailer they go this is the lead trailer
anybody who gets a lead on show this is
the trove again and they said you know
Kerry always just use this last week I'm
the triple minutes with me like sniffing
the couches totally having a shower you
coming touch this chair right here but
you need cash in Elwes his brother that
Kerry always uh and then and then but I
finally met Alan
for the second time we have some history
before that but I finally met him for
real and we got it was real the first
time it was real for me is the setting I
read a restaurant on the Upper West Side
I said black beans no that's it okay
then I mean Harry's on burritos in the
mid-90s exactly happening and then but
cut forward to like 2000 - we met on we
did Firefly Firefly is that we goes
first Matt that's where we talk our
bigger geek bona fides there yeah um so
you've worked with Whedon and that means
like if in the kingdom of heaven you
will be welcome does one of the two of
the Apostles of everyone let's do that
oh cool Joss Whedon's Jesus yeah I'm
ready for that once you've hit the
engine like that well ok fishes on the
table
alright so but but aside from that aside
from Firefly that you guys voice
cartoons right DC [ __ ] characters
right who have you done separately
together I know you did I didn't learn
Lantern one I didn't
did you do Superman I did green arrow a
couple of times then I was Superman dad
you got to do Superman as well I know in
a dickish what was that like a Koosh
Superman
yeah that's one which one super ding uh
this last one then the one who's like
I'm not gonna fly around backwards
because that wouldn't hurt time I must
say he was younger so he wasn't quite he
didn't have a maturity to it which one
was it you remember my Makapuu Josefa
I remember it was good there's a lot
they really should send her to you come
out yeah that's nice legit we getting
hung up at my business we got and they
send us a DVD recently this is straight
out of fat man I'm Batman on it it was
young like Universal home video sent to
us a custom done case for straight out
of Compton but instead of compliment
said fat man on Batman hey I was so
[ __ ] proud of myself I texted it to
my mom to look mom T dinner's all over
Twitter is your captain our show it's
crazy I'm alright so hold on he was also
vigilante I was
did you really voice vigilante I was
vigilant you way back well thanks for
remembering man thank you
so wait but then is Trevor I did Steve
Trevor I was in that Wonder Woman
balloons girlfriend perfect that's about
right he held it straight down vs.
weight on the back so now what was the
one before after before Steve Trevor
vigilante vigilante justice league
unlimited but they didn't do like they
let him live right visual landing at the
end of the [ __ ] Commodore not bad
vision to the western vigilant oh okay
that means our cat will head cartoon is
shitty shooters
motorcycle yeah the car we did what just
pillage joss whedon stuff they would say
let's go to Angel now and pick that one
that one that one and put them into the
Justice League Unlimited it feels like
the folks who worked on the show are big
fans of Buffy fireflies you know what
when someone has already gone out to
find a really great talent it kind of
does your job for you come on all you
have to do is go to that show and it's
perfect it's Michigan pasty for all the
intermingling fandoms coming together
it's so satisfying for me as a fan to I
love it which brings us back to con man
so you guys are sitting there going we
got no [ __ ] loot nobody's seen it we
don't want to keep the loot we don't
want to give control over they're gonna
[ __ ] ruin it you decide to do it
yourselves
right why crowdsource financing
because we we knew the fans it wouldn't
be asking you know a group of nobodies
or people that were just guessing or out
there we've been going to conventions
for years and have physically met people
all for a decade at that point even more
and so we went out to the fans knowing
there's also spectrum within conman
which is the show that got canceled in
comment so it will be our Firefly in
comment a spectrum and it gave us an
opportunity saw a little bit in that
clip of I'm flying a spaceship and he's
captaining the spaceship so it was a
quick opportunity for us to get back in
those positions again and we thought
fans would like to see that and then
it's also a comedy and it's an it's a
comedy about that world of cons so if
people like cons they might want to see
this and they did they we raised over a
million dollars in the first day and
what was that like dude like you know
you launched a Kickstarter or an
IndieGoGo or crowler's or something like
that and you're like wow we got a number
we hope we hit what happens when you hit
a million dollars and you're like oh my
gosh should have done this when I was
[ __ ] 15 ask people for money like is
crazy also called homeless yeah there's
that just like you guys going over the
moon like oh my god we're [ __ ] set
like what was your target what number
were you trying to get to hey well we
didn't want to ask people hey we want to
do 10 episodes that circuit we said we
want to show you this it was really
important for us to get at least one
episode out right we put in our own
money just to make sure we at least do
on and then if people wanted to see it
we put it on that cloud funding as much
as they wanted to see we had push goals
mm-hmm can I just say I adore Canadian
adorable it is that you were like you
took it down and not should be like we
put in our own money we're in Hollywood
that's the thing we're like we put in
our own money really we did we have a
cetera I'm I get terrified about things
like this like if it doesn't work like
I'll be heartbroken so let's make sure
it at least works on see you got 11 cuz
at the end of the day if it's like if it
never happens beyond this its we got
something that we sit around and watch
and we [ __ ] love and we did it and I
got to work together
we got to man he got Alan is the kind of
guy forgive me just continuing on here
where he says you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna learn play guitar and write a
couple songs oh he's my two weeks later
he's done it because he takes guitar
lessons from three different guys and
starts writing stuff and starts doing
stuff okay you're back same thing with
gone man he said I've been thinking
about the site he was kicking it around
for years he's I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do this any sat down and he did it
to fruition to the whole thing it was
amazing which begs the question like how
do you hang out with an irritating
overachiever like that someone who has a
vision and executes send or elevates
funny you should say that there's a look
there's a lovely balance there because
Alan is first of all very very modest
but if but if life if there's a if
there's a banana peel in life Alan's the
guy steps up so it really levels the
playing field it really does it's nice
it does it helps writing though to when
you write a guy who steps on every
banana peel I stepped on a few so I know
where they all are you gotta be smart
enough to like you see you guys Lana
banana peel you jump on his back cuz
that's a free ride oh that's me and you
just alright so you guys did you shot
the one well first a week we went so we
we were just gonna get one they were ten
minute episodes it actually worked in
half-hour format so three would make one
story line of the half-hour and then
there were three three three and three
and they blew past those and then we
wanted to do a comic book about spectrum
the show within the show we actually
want to do a novel but the novel starts
after they leave Earth and we figured a
comic would be a great way to get them
off earth and then put them in space
with the novel it's also for the
audience like you know they're like yeah
you're like here's a book come on and
reading here's a column yeah so then so
we did the con we said alright if you
guys want to keep supporting this comic
book that got funded the novel got
funded and then we have a video game
that we wanted to do also that we just
think
around like would it be great to have a
convivial game where you set up your own
con and you get to bring in your own
celebrities and you're trying to build
your farmville for pads yeah it's got
like a sim a sim element to it it's
quite brilliant you can battle the look
on comes out I'm the guy goes you want
to make a game good luck and then I look
and I go wow
maybe that is actually fun I would play
that [ __ ] game on the [ __ ] cool if
I'm bringing mark millar it's gonna be
free it'll be out on you know for all
your whatever they're called smartphones
yeah but there's a way beyond equivalent
devices web enabled devices at comic-con
we hope to sometimes we'll say coming
soon
but wait we've been doing it since
comment finished shooting like capsule
our Dave wrap the next urn anyway we
want you direct yeah so you wrote
directed and acted yeah so you've been
acting your whole life right and you sit
there and you what you've sat behind a
number of [ __ ] directors and some
you're like that's great and some you're
like Jesus Christ I wish I was in charge
yeah you finally step up and do it hey I
feel like I'm go backwards now
like what aren't absolutely God
absolutely really I just did a movie and
I was trying to get gas okay I'll work
no no it's it's so much easier my acting
is the best gig of them all as far as if
you want to be you know just work right
because I get to requires talent like
that's the thing like you guys could
step into roles because you got talent
and stuff like that but for some people
it's like you have to write and direct
and edit yourself otherwise I'm not
gonna put in [ __ ] what but you took the
job man like to the to the other side
did it make you want to do it more or
less I think doing a comment season two
it'll be hard to step back go backwards
but on this movie that I just did I was
so calm when things were going wrong you
know yeah there's a good reason for this
I'm pretty sure you're they're never
really there to trying their best guys
come on come on we're up against it
right now because you can't yeah you
know when it all gets in your head like
you just you see all these crises is
converging and you can't stop you have
to just keep going forward this is not a
problem it's we kept saying this is not
a problem you just lost your actress
today before that's a problem how
do we know me no we know a lot it's not
your hablo guys have an analyst well
people you can pull from yes I mean
worked with both of you were so many
people together and separately that was
a great thing too we totally planned on
calling in favors saying hey we're doing
this thing we really want you and we
thought it would be a little bit like
pulling teeth come to come to our little
our little show and turns we're running
out of roles to put people in people
were interested in calling us who did
you get tell tell everybody who's a side
you guys you know um uh okay Wow so who
else is in it Tricia Helfer Tricia
Helfer Michael trucco yes um
Alison castle Felicia Day who should day
Joss Whedon okay Henry Rollins is an
Imagine I got to direct Henry Rollins
see Henry Ron's tie me to a chair and
threatened me with a cake server it was
pretty great guys couldn't find any
knives Summer Glau Gina Torres Sean
Maher a lot of the fire Joel Joel state
it isn't um chopping Shawn ashes yeah
Seth Green Seth Green um so everybody
everybody loves and what did you do you
shoot at cons to make a convenient or
general oh we did some we did some yeah
just j-unit everyone's and stuff so what
do you have to set up your own yeah Tom
yeah so yeah that was and to make it
look right and not just kind of go you
know just have this many things not like
what your eyes does kind of kind of like
that's not good I'll be a hat not one to
see Amy did a comic-con four feet by
four feet entourage one I was like
that's impressive
well I got the signage until they go
pretty sign yeah you need things hanging
up on the you know we had some floating
rabbits from everybody loves fine that's
what it's called
everyone loves fine they sell our
t-shirts I should know this it's good to
be buying everybody see seems a ball the
information he's your pensive anything
you can't remember we love you puts in
there we love fine that's I don't know
about everybody will see you know it's a
Harry Potter reference just keep going I
know
Suz their season - coming hopefully
fingers crossed idli hopefully we are
planning on it right now it would be
great because the comic book comes out
on Free Comic Book Day the and then when
is Free Comic Book Day this year may 7th
sir eat is the book Don you've seen it
all or is that I've seen yeah the first
one is all finish she are too funny you
guys never didn't come really large just
even looking on your whole life and
actually this is one you're kind of
responsible for it didn't get he's on
the cover he looks great
you'd look good on it man think thank
you get you could you've got into I like
anything that looks like me only more
handsome little a little younger yeah
wait till you see me it's a lot if you
can control again the flick uh you we
see in the trailer a [ __ ] huge tiled
[ __ ] mm-hm yeah there's a nude scene
that you do and so they tiled you out
and it looked like you're [ __ ]
dangling this stuff like yeah so in the
comics it'd be even bigger because there
are no special effects budget some
oysters it's like you turn the page and
you've just got a paid special
additional Z just keeps going the
alright we can't let you out of here
though without talking about a Firefly
both of them get both you give us a my
favorite dot that you must have a
[ __ ] forty-six at your disposal throw
like knives my favorite my most recent
favorite moment ivory watched it we
watched them its objects in space mm-hmm
when that were boarded from a Huebel
early yeah Jubal Early comes onboard and
there's a moat like he he comes on board
in the middle of space like they didn't
land anywhere so there's no way this guy
came on the ship and he's sneaking
around the ship and Captain Mal comes
around the corner and he comes around
the other cord they just happened to hit
face to face and there's this moment of
what are you and then you just start
biting it second um huh what what it is
so cool but you did get your ass kicked
oh yeah constantly billion off of gather
he was really good at getting beaten up
there was a moment it's not so much in
an episode but there was an episode
where we had about were transporting a
bunch of cows and steaks or a short
supply and at the end of the episode
we're all sitting around a big table and
we're enjoying steak that day filming
that scene was in the morning and that
was with the one right before lunch so
they called lunch and we're all sitting
on a table with steaks in front of us so
some people got up and went off for
lunch the camera grabs a couple of a
stayed in costume on the ship and ate
lunch this space lunch lunch and it felt
it felt good it was moments like that
that made that set that little area feel
like oh it had rocking chairs it had
cook cushy old crappy furniture you'd
find in a flea market just kind of found
bits and it would feel it felt very
homey where'd you guys shoot Vancouver
no we shared that right at 20th Century
Fox usually that was shot down the
state's just age 12 I want to say stage
12 for somebody's I'm gonna say memory
no no when you're passing by 20 Century
Fox on Pico yeah it's the one the first
one right there because you're left as
you're gone east but yep I went to a
party there recently there was a party a
big party in that isn't that soundstage
I said where I've been all right ah
I had a spaceship right here it was a
bit but right where that bar is was a
big old turbine
yeah one's over there who's that was me
wrong George is born booze yeah nobody
cares what I do
how often do all you guys get together
it's hard for us all to get together
jewel is in Vancouver I see people
individually summer just came I did an
episode of Castle Chad did one recently
oh right you're coming to do one so I
see people who work Gina's done one um
Lorraine is out in New York Raina's in
New York I just got hurt a little while
after me yes I saw her comic-con guy saw
her come
she's dead pulling she's dead Pope she's
in bed he's learning that she's in hip
yeah trailers looks okay a lot of
trailer looks fantastic squad trailer
yeah
it looks fantastic
oh what an expert of this you are I
don't envy change like comrade try to
recreate the Joker character I don't
envy anybody who has to do that so
reimagine think about it man like there
was a time where Heath Ledger had to
reimagine Jack Nicholson's Joker and we
were all like impossible the guy from
[ __ ] up Brokeback and now no one ever
mentions Jack Nicholson sugars all about
are we gonna get over heat so maybe
letõs got like a you know [ __ ] rabbit
man in his back I certainly hope I'm
very interested to see what he does and
I don't envy that position at all right
uh yeah nobody's asking us to play The
Joker though hey let me do they really
get totally did looking could you
imagine like a huge bloke oh I feel like
that changes the character tirely game
has changed the the show is called con
man Yin can they see it they can see it
right now on Vimeo and if you want to
check out the show within the show
spectrum then Free Comic Book Day
spectrum comes out you can get a taste
and then the regular series comes out
after that helpful information what
regular oh the regular series in the
comic comes out of there oh yeah yeah
that's the first they don't you to do
one no no no we're doing we're doing for
it is P level yeah you're looking royal
oh my god the girl they got to do yard
incredible you have to if I can go with
them everywhere man you look good -
you're like Flavor Flav it's my little
oh you need a clock we said clock hey um
we got a trailer to schooi is [ __ ] egg
i believe it i know don't talk over cuz
there's discussion before the show about
should we talk over let it be man let it
breathe alright so this is a trailer and
it up and then go to give him a [ __ ]
two-shot okay
look into this camera and set it up this
camera yep so what you're first gonna
see is a there's a lot of breath a lot
of hot breath ah first you're gonna see
the the trailer for comment and then i
think right
that you're gonna see a little scene
where Nathan and I are on our spaceship
and and that's it smoke okay yeah okay
just watching watch watch watch me here
we go man check it out but it out eat I
don't know buddy bad Trevor you do pop
body yeah science fiction is supposed to
be about the future why are the feds so
obsessed with the past are you merely
they think that you're a spaceship pilot
their reality damn you make it out to
Kevin but it out either
okay that's like Jordan I've never seen
you in one of these things I've been
hired to play dance I just I think I'm
on the line a little bit more like a
fussbudget last but not least cake okay
okay okay
I have been in films plays circuses and
snuff films did you say snuff films yes
we botched the ending though Andy Serkis
and I have very very different camp
actors you see food look at the your
money circus give me a hug Oscar what's
next Curious George
then a Japanese guy juggling knives back
there you smashed on sake so much you
should be too
I've been practicing my impression of
you we're gonna lose it I've got this I
hate science fiction fans turkeys and
awards are the only sense of self-worth
that I have I had his sucked so far up
my own ass nice Allah swears this end
there's a scene after as well oh I will
be there was that one where I was naked
I don't know what we have you guys yeah
that was yeah it's like a dream sequence
that's happening with us you ever want a
tea tile dick everyone's the tile to
dick yeah let's check that out
the tiles victim it's so cold why am I
so cold
they're naked what the hell is wrong
with my dick it's all blurry no Brenda
I'm dr. Cholewa astrobiologist on the
spaceship spectrum duh
Jack's not even that good I should have
been famous one you look great Hawaiian
shirt
come on Nathan we were amazing in that
sink I know right so good I couldn't
even I couldn't that's how stealth you
were in that performance fantastic
standing um look I applaud anybody that
puts digital come in anything think that
joke was good good job right there I was
sitting there gonna [ __ ] why didn't I do
that that's [ __ ] funny [ __ ] alright
so they see it on Vimeo yeah sue season
two like make sure you do it I know it's
like a pain in the dick and whatnot and
it always seems like an easier thing
you're like I want to [ __ ] do this
and then the middle of it yeah yeah but
it's worth it like oh my God look at
that you're in charge you know what I'm
saying like no you spend most of your
time somebody being like go do this
you're like okay is the one time you're
like go do this and you're saying okay
to yourself do more of it you your
career [ __ ] you you need help you
need help with your career keep doing
what you do man take representing
[ __ ] Canada well we were talking
before the show about he shouldn't go to
go to for shot she's been [ __ ]
Alberta man so he was there during the
gretzky years town I remember one time
his little park Hazeldine right across
the street Black Hawk pizza Wayne
Gretzky walked in our we waved my
Gretzky and he turned around I'll never
forget this he meant hey right there
without the fields we animus on that
soil I didn't know any young great with
the Gretzky field right there a piece of
pizza stuck right here that would Oh
photos tender emotional is that
Detective uh alan tudyk nathan fillion
thank you for being our first [ __ ]
guests ever hey hey you popped up Jerry
yeah you should have blowed the cherry
mmm gum like this good thanks for being
here man from fat man I'm Batman I've
been Kevin Smith Markman Arden and
you've been alan tudyk and Nathan
feeling like that class in class right
that Whedon class on the show now what
we're talking about join us next week
we're only downhill after that
yeah just given a show guys this is
dropping the mic cuz and Dinah come back
anytime we won't be here saying that
that time same bat Channel which is
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder